each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
this is the software engineering track
data-driven software engineering and I
welcome you all to this and our first
speaker today man oh by the way my name
is Judith bishop and I'm the director of
computer science in external research
and this is the first time we've
actually had a long track at the faculty
summit and it is five sessions long so
we've got three today into tomorrow and
we hope you're going to be able to get
to all of them and our first speaker
we're delighted to have his Antony
Finkelstein who is from University
College London and he is the professor
of software systems engineering there he
also has many men many awards and you
can read all about them in his biography
but not to take too much time from him
i'm just going to mention one we were
absolutely thrilled to see him up on the
stage in captain @ XE where he received
the award for his outstanding
contribution to software engineering
internationally Anthony over to you well
thank you very much indeed Judith and
it's a very good to see the software
engineering community so well
represented at this event and I
obviously Rick recognize many people in
the in the author in the audience I'll
go and find my clicker here so yes I
can't make the funny noises I'll just
have to do it this this way if I
occasionally groan that's nothing to do
with trying to move the slides on so
since that I'm from University College
London and since we've got such a global
audience I thought they would would say
so University College London is one of
the constituent colleges of the
University of London we're located in
Bloomsbury in central in central London
we're effectively though it says college
in the title
we're effectively a standalone
University in our own right with a
stroke with a comprehensive set of
activities right across the area from
arts and humanities through to through
to a large concentration in the
biomedicals in the biomedical sciences
there are I think three of my other
colleagues from from UCL here at the
faculty at the faculty summit
representing some of the different areas
we have in the specializations so I feel
somewhat in some trepidation in giving
this talk because I'm intending very
much to present a highly speculative
sketch so you've seen already a whole
lot of people presenting material that's
that's very well for tap that's very
well thought out and I'm going to
immediately break that because i'm going
to put forward some new idea some
suggestions for new directions I've been
very privileged that I'm going to be
giving this talk alongside Fred worden
from Microsoft who's going to present a
complimentary view about some of the
things that are currently being done in
microsoft which contribute towards the
creation of software ecosystems so my my
talk has the usual sort of rhetorical
structure I'm going to spend quite a
time in fact on on motivation I'm going
to set the study of software ecosystems
a little bit in in context I'm going to
make some observations about about
current progress in the area of software
ecosystems and in related fields I'm
going to posit some questions some
research questions and then I'm going to
make some suggestions both about the
sort of
analyses which might be done in order to
underpin this this area and also some
make some suggestions as to what we
might expect by way of outcomes from the
from the area in a talk which is
entirely speculative the stuff Mart with
asterisks is sort of super speculative
there are other less polite terms for it
but I won't go there this Adam supposed
this woman's been ever up in in
Microsoft inglourious in glorious
Technicolor in this way that's
commissioner neelie crus who was the
former european commissioner responsible
for competition policy and she's not the
most popular person in the immediate
term a few miles from this spot spot
here for fairly obvious reasons and she
was digression together with her
predecessor responsible for the European
Commission's decision of March 2004 and
many people will know will know
something of the decision of the
European Commission which had two parts
the first concerned video playing and
about what could be done about the
provision of video players and video
formats within windows and I'm not going
to talk a lot about that but the second
part of the of the Commission's position
of march two thousand four concerned the
a alleged monopoly that Microsoft held
in the area of workgroup server
operating systems and
the the Commission decided and
subsequently upheld by the European
Court of the first instance that
Microsoft should be required to supply
what was called interoperability
information for the purpose of allowing
a competitor's to develop and
distributed workgroup server operating
system products now there's a long
history of dispute which follows on to
this to do with the adequacy or
otherwise of the information Microsoft
provided and I was involved in providing
expert advice during that dispute but
here by is the felt I should complement
the photographs and what were not sure
with his hands up is about the hitter or
not and the interoperability information
was interpreted by the Commission to
mean the protocols implemented in
Windows workgroup server operating
systems and there's a pretty broad
definition of protocol here meaning sets
of rules of interconnection interact of
interaction between workgroup server
operating systems server operating
systems and client operating systems
across distributed net across
distributed networks so why am I
recounting this history because an
interesting problem arises it was the
intent of the European Commission that
they enable competitors to develop their
own workgroup server operating systems
that could operate in heterogeneous
environments alongside Microsoft's
alongside Microsoft's products now for
commercial reasons which we could
discuss over lunch or
or whatever it is that never that hasn't
term that hasn't happened but what's
quite interesting is the the extent to
which actually the interoperability
information that Microsoft were required
was required to provide by the European
Commission has in fact empowered
Microsoft's own software ecosystem a
term subsequently to be defined so here
we see something which is a problem
which is on an interesting tipping point
the release of specification and
information which on the one hand can
allow people to substitute products for
those of Microsoft's own but on the
other side of that that tipping point
actually permit the development of
interoperable prod interoperable
products that actually support support
the development of Microsoft's ecosystem
and hence increases the viability
commercially and otherwise of their
technol of their technologies so this is
a very interesting interesting balance
balancing point so to take a couple of
brinster a couple of four instances you
could ask whether or not the whether or
not the ability of of the sandbar
open-source team to have access to
protocol information about interaction
with Microsoft's work group workgroup
server operating systems in facts where
in fact the commercial advantage in the
availability of that information
actually actually lies and you may well
say that actually the existence of Samba
and products like systems like Samba
actually or contributions
to the viability of Microsoft's products
within naturally heterogeneous
enterprise environments similarly you
might look at the core of Microsoft's of
server operating systems for example
Active Directory an Active Directory
replication and asked yourself whether
or not the ability of other products to
understand how that such replication
takes place might or might not actually
enable a dynamic ecosystem to to exist
so we'll return to these questions in a
moment and I don't take a position I'm
just asking the question okay so this is
another personal example so openbravo is
a open source and open source erp system
it's produced by a initially developed
by a company based in in northern Spain
where there's probably still celebrating
at this moment and I was asked by a VC
to do due diligence because they were
thinking of making a major investment in
open in openbravo well how do you
actually make an assessment about you do
a technology due diligence on an open
source on open source product like this
well it's quite it's quite difficult
because you know normally if you do such
due diligence on a normal commercial
product it you know you look at their
their processes you look at their
various process repositories and so on
and you can use that as a basis for for
understanding how they go about their
business but he
year you have a product which is really
incredibly embedded in its in an inner
software ecosystem in other in order to
understand that I need to be able to
understand how customers depart partners
developers and others actually interplay
in other words I need to know something
about the community about the ecosystem
within which openbravo within which
openbravo resides the company itself is
not viable outside that network of other
community community players if the
developer ecosystem is not healthy then
the company is not firm is not healthy
and to a certain extent that boils down
to an architectural question about
whether or not the underlying software
architecture is actually such that it
enables those things to examine to exist
so a third example which is lets me give
a rather bizarre impression of my
overall working life actually but set
that aside I was giving a talk in
another VC called that time logic spring
and now call at A&M and they'd asked me
to talk to see Toews of their portfolio
companies about what sort of software
platforms they should be they should be
using and I was given a title ii to talk
about the platform gamble so i get i
gave up quite a lot of thought to this
and i came i had a layered reference
model not not entirely surprising later
reference model and i talked about you
know making decisions and saying that
you know the i believe that the
interlayer risk in most technology
stacks is reducing but that the
interlayer risk might be increasing and
i was trying to talk about how you make
balances in choosing the technology
snack and i discovered that actually
this was wholly uninteresting to the
CTOs that i was speaking to and you may
make up I'm building up a track record
here but a little dissent but the reason
why it was wholly uninteresting was that
in the area these people were operating
in there where what you might call
software spheres of influence most of
the companies they were concerned with
producing technologies for supply chains
logistics and supply chains and their
worlds are dominated by the existence of
large ERP ERP systems so their
technology decisions are driven not by
what you might think is the optimal risk
balanced approach to selecting a set of
technologies that you might use for your
stack actually their decision-making was
very much driven by their placing their
technical and commercial placing within
a software ecosystem within a sphere of
influence of a particular class of ER
your ERP system be that the SAP ERP
system be it Microsoft family of erp
related products be it Oracle's suite of
ERP systems and that actually their
choices were driven by by their places
in the ecosystem and that was a wake-up
call that was a wake-up call for me
certainly in trying to understand this
area so now I want to make I think what
I suspect may be some more controversial
observations so in some senses you'd
look at at research in in the area of
software engineering and you can see a
very strong thread of research that's
that's gone from you know the
traditional world of monolithic system
a more or less successful track of
research on on component on component
reuse more thing now into ongoing
research on on component marketplaces
which itself has now morphed into a
large stream of work reflected it to you
know services conferences and others on
on service on service broker brokering
and you know you can find any number of
papers written on written on those top
on those topics and I describe that as
being you know very much a focus on on
fine grain relatively fine grain reuse
and lots of research and here I extend
this controversially I would say that
actually its application in in the real
world has been relatively has been
relatively limited by contrast I don't
need to do that do I just click by
contrast what we see is a another track
of how to describe it another track
where what you've got is people building
in a built for purpose systems and
you've got a whole other people
basically acquiring software packages
large coarse grain collections of
function of functionality and leveraging
the functionality in those large coarse
grain packages and by way of glue air
and interchange formats and local
squirmin of local scripting and that's
been morphing into the whole area of of
supply of supply chains so traditionally
you know supply chains has been
something that you know manufacturing
people concern themselves with but has
not been something that we in the
software engineering world have
considered have considered very much but
I'd like to put it to the two to you
that in fact we are now very much
finding ourselves in a traditional in
software engineering in supply chain in
supply chain settings and i'll describe
little bit more what that might what
that might entail but this sort of
coarse grain exploitation of
functionality for the construction of
systems across communities has in fact
been very little researched but it is in
fact a dominant mode of using there in
the community so now I in a talk which
is already ninety percent digression I
digress I digress again I believe that
the boundaries between software
engineering research and business
research had been made artificially too
high I I very firmly believe that we
need a new rap rational between
technology research and business
research I mean I believe very firmly
for example that many of the current
challenges about engineering systems in
in clouds will require us to have a much
more sophisticated understanding of for
example cloud business models in order
to make some of the technical decisions
we need we need to make I believe that
trying to understand software
development
processes outside of an understanding
about how you know business and
procurement is undertaken is actually a
fundamentally missed mistaken endeavor
so I believe that there's a strong need
to rebuild these threads together I have
to say I don't think there are very many
good examples of what such a new
repression or might look like but I I
believe that it's important so just a
brief couple of observations on some of
the the subjects that have there have
been some work done on on the area of
acquisition of coarse grain saw packages
and there has been a thread about about
that one and the couple of interesting
things have been drawn to attention
there one is the fact that you start in
understanding the business of how to
acquire a software package by actually
looking at what distinguishes offerings
rather than what all the offerings
possess so you're quite interested
actually in writing specifications which
don't set out the full range of
functionality but might act effectively
in order to distinguish different
software packages that you might acquire
the next thing I would observe is that
the area of software packages suddenly
and this is relevant to software highly
relevant to software ecosystems suddenly
asks us to make decisions out what I
call balancing mutability traditionally
in in the area of software engineering
and software specification we've been
very concerned with that we that we we
find out what users want and we write a
specification we construct a system in
order to
meet that specificity in order to meet
that specification crudely okay in
software package acquisition we all know
that's not the case because what you do
is you say okay well you know classic
example is you buy an ERP system and you
have to do things their SAP the
Microsoft the Oracle the Oracle way if
that's not the way you're currently
doing your invoice processing then you
change the way you do your invoice
processing to do it that to do it that
way because it's cheaper it's the
obvious thing to do and so what you have
is a balance of mutability your balance
of change ability sometimes you changed
the organizational system round the the
product sometimes you have to change the
product but you decide the way that
you're doing your business is business
critical is where you get your
competitive advantage from and so on and
so on and so on I'll say less about the
business of aligning ontology so I think
that's an important area as well part of
the problem of acquiring the software
packages is actually aligning the
ontology is within the different
packages so that you can make a
judicious comparison of what the
features that are being offered by the
competitive offerings are okay so Matt
supply chains I thought what I would do
is just illustrate this very briefly
with a with an example essentially
slightly elderly example I bought a
laptop and the laptop had a had it was a
typical problem eunuch hardware by mum
by del operating system by by microsoft
controller to control the pcmcia slot by
a third party supplier 3g card by
another supplier build from a third
supplier aggregated for my university by
a not yet another by yet another
company and and so on and can I get the
blinking thing to work end-to-end no
okay I can't again you may say it's my
technical in competence but the the
point of the story here is not to yet
again for you know outline that the
point of story is that where does that's
a complex supply chain and where does
the responsibility for what aspects of
the technology functioning actually
reside and how can i locate that within
this within this supply supply chain and
assuming that you know the fix is not at
my end bitters that somehow are located
within that broader supply chain who fit
who actually fixes who actually fixes
that where does that fix go and where is
that fix most stable E and best made in
the commercial interests of the supply
chain as a whole so the whole set of
interesting things but given that we're
now in these complex supply chains how
do we deal with issues like who controls
evolution the evolution and who is
responsible for assuming what what risks
you have in additional sorts of supplier
risks associated with the fact that
you're you know you're getting your
technology pulled down from different
threads in that in that supply chain so
what happens in that setting so the
interesting thing I mean the word
ecosystem I've used it without
definition and I'm probably going to not
spend too much time on on the niceties
of semantics but here we have in some
sense as a community of interacting
organisms so here we have a community of
interacting software development players
and what's more the important thing our
ecosystems is it also includes the
physical environments within which they
reside the resources on which they can
draw and sometimes people refer to
software Ecology's I think it's it's
better to adopt a consistent terminology
and think of the study of software
ecosystems as being essentially the
study of of ecology and then you get
other terms like symbiosis which is
clearly what exists in many of these
ecosystems we're discussing which is the
interaction between different organ
organ isms within the same the same
setting ideally two mutual firm to
mutual advantage I mean there are other
models like parasitism which we could
discuss as well so I mean it's very
interesting if you go to any software
development website what you see ma'am
is what you see here on you know
something that looks like that what's on
the left here which is a whole long list
that's the one for openbravo actually a
whole lot long list of their of their
part of their partners and in fact if
you go to any sort of modern software
company you know actually you know like
you start up things like that that's on
the front page you have to be really big
it to be like Microsoft before you don't
you know put your bigger friends on the
on the front page of your website and
you can see here that you know Microsoft
Oracle and others new invest but you
know a large amount of time and money in
sustaining and built will heal more hear
more about that in sustaining and
building their partner networks another
interesting area is the development of
plugins and communities round round
plugins this is from the adobe photoshop
market marketplace enabled x x adobe but
i think the whole area of plugins is
interesting both from you know from a
commercial point of view
from an architectural point a point of
view and about how it is that product
successfully construct such dynamic
communities there's also the whole area
about about what you might call skills
communities so depends how you want to
consider this what what happier wearing
or what set of filters you're using but
you you clearly got very dynamic
communities around around particular
development development paradigms and
particular sets of collection of skills
and again large companies spend invest
heavily in sustaining their ecosystem by
trying to sustain the body of skills
which underpin their technologies you
have a AP eyes and again you know the
design of AP eyes are very largely about
how you are designing your ecosystem the
broader your API the more opportunities
you offer you offer up but the more of
the of your own commercial space that
you're actually you may be restricted
restricting so you can consider the
design of AP I'm you can consider the
design of AP is as effectively steps in
the design of us of an ecosystem so here
are some research challenges okay how do
you if you've got a product to offer how
do you enable an ecosystem around your
offering how exactly do you make that
that trade-off between complementarity
in other words I want to enable people
to offer complimentary offerings while
restricting the ability of others to
substitute their products
for yours in others retaining your
integrity within your particular
competitive niche how do you you know
how do you leverage unique as an
ecosystem and how within an ecosystem do
you identify what might be viable viable
niches are there any way of
understanding these ecosystems
structurally so that you can seek
business opportunities within them ok
what this is a mum and further you know
what makes a community live what makes a
a sovereign ecosystem you know die nap
dynamic a classic way in which this just
discussing this with Bashar no saber
before and before the you know before
the talk the question is you know you
see that a large number of open source
projects that are on sourceforge you
know don't work they don't they fail as
open source projects and that they fail
because they fail to build dynamic
communities around themselves and
actually understanding how that might
take places are very interesting it is a
very interesting question how do we look
at what are at trajectories in other
words when you're building a software
ecosystem you're not looking purely at
the situation as it is now but you're
looking at how this might evolve given
the independent trajectories of
different development efforts I just
wanted to point here on on the side so I
think the very interesting work that's
been done on the application of real
auction theory in the development of
interfaces work of Kevin Sullivan most
know most notably where I think there is
some interesting interplay about the
idea about treating a interface
effectively as an optional future
expansion of your system
it's a exciting area they're open
standards are also a very interesting
area and it's quite interesting that
we've got a we've got a real clash in
our community which is sort of things
whereas in most other areas of of
engineering Oh standards are used to
provide norms baseline best pract
baseline best practices in our community
on the whole open standards used in
rather different way by skeletons for
future around which future developments
take place so I think there's an
interesting question about the role of
standards open standards in the creation
of software ecosystems we might look at
you know the w3c four examples both of
the successful creation of ecosystems
and for their room and for their and for
the way in which the w3c ever so killed
development of some areas through the
promulgation of standards so I said I
would term and I'm aware at the time I
think I said I would outline some
possible approaches to studying at this
area I mean I think there's some
interesting analyses that can be done on
the area of API usage I think we need
some real serious study on the area of
plug-in architectures and plug-in
markets which I don't know how has been
done it's fairly obvious that social
network analysis might play an
interesting role in this in this area
some of you who know my work know that
we had on a recent paper a Dixie on a
tool for analyzing looking at using
social network metrics to identify
stakeholders in complex requirements
settings and I envisage that sort of
direction of work as being something
that might be extended in the area of
software eco
software ecosystems there's a very big
community actually of people in station
up in the area of marketing who work on
what's called sentiment analyses so for
example what they do in the example
product this is meeting mine what they
do actually developed by some
ex-microsoft people what they do is mine
large corpora of corporate data looking
for indicators of of sentiment looking
for particular and exactly how to how to
describe isn't looking for particular
words phrases and sequences of
interactions which might suggest to them
which have emotional content I think it
might be quite interesting to apply this
to the area of of software ecosystems to
look at you know at what makes
communities software communities live or
not live what the the social content of
the interactions these interactions
might be I also think that it may be
well appropriate to apply ethnographic
analyses which ibly applied quite
successfully in similar settings to look
at particularly studies of open source
to look at how that might take place so
what are the potential outcomes the
ability to engineer ecosystems I believe
is it is important the ability to
actually consciously where the ability
to manage the growth and evolution of
the ecosystems of which we form a part
and I hope a new synthesis of research
on business models and software
engineering and with that I'll stop now
and invite we've decided that the way
a head should be there are any immediate
questions for me we'll do that now then
they may be immediate questions for
Freddie follows on from me and then we
might have a collective wrap up well
where we discuss the intersections of
the two areas and at the back so you
know looking at this interaction between
business and social engineering like you
talked about are you are you talking
about developing perhaps more
sophisticated requirements for the
software systems as well as the
processes by which these are implemented
or something more than that maybe
leading into maybe some more flexible
architectures or knowledge-based
architectures things like that ok well
let me give let me give a a first
exemplar of the sort of thing that that
I think can be done and then try and
move it along to answer your to answer
your questions so there have been a lot
of has been a lot of ongoing research
about how requirements engineering and
software specification and software
architecture ought to be done long
strand standings that have researched
theme streams in that area but that has
often been Sean from an understanding
about procurements sales and business
processes round ack was a round back
position so often these these approaches
have failed not because they've because
they are technically flawed because they
are inappropriate for the business
setting in which they're in in which
they're embedded similarly you might
envisage that architectures which are
which are technically feasible but which
are where is very difficult to construct
business models which will deliver
revenue to the relevant players around
them are lots going to be or not going
to be feasible so I think it'd be very
interesting to sort of try and bring
business modeling and analysis and the
study of architectures together I
apologize that I'm not able to give you
out you know down the line thing because
it is a speculation okay we'll just take
a question here from Bashar and then
we'll keep yours relevant so it's really
just a follow-up comment or question
which is which is maybe that maybe
ecosystems are there to be discovered as
opposed to engineered in many ways I
mean the question about whether there
are requirements for these is a question
about scope you know you can you can
scope it as a project you can scope it
as a wider system or you can scope it as
the entire world and I think some of the
difficulties that that I think we're
going to face are deciding when to stop
asking who might be a stakeholder or who
might be a relevant authority that might
impact the project and so on the one
hand it would be nice to I mean one of
your conclusions was how do we engineer
these ecosystems I mean maybe that's
that's not the right question it's how
do we discover what ecosystems are most
relevant for the sites that you do so
methodologically it may well be that the
best approach to do is to study our
existing examples of successful dynamic
ecosystems and understand what what does
that so that's a research methodology
quick research methodology question I
understand that it is in the creek that
it is in the critical commercial
interest of players in this setting that
they are part of such of such ecosystems
and then that the answer that is no
beliefs critical commercial trip
concerns to chance and therefore they
want to take such actions that enable a
successful a successful ecosystem to
take part and that to take two tickets
and that may mean that you do not take
you do not necessarily you know locally
optimize on business opportunities
because the global optimization that's
required in the Cree
of a community is is more and it may
mean that you create you know
architectural flame works which are
somewhat different then you might create
if you were in a position just looking
within yourself many many years and many
many patents and we're going to see what
he can tell us from Microsoft view about
open thanks thank you very much I have a
question for everybody if you were to
rank microsoft apple google and IBM how
would you do it in terms of who's the
most open in terms of their ecosystem
obviously Anthony had a slide where it
showed everybody had partner networks
and it's pretty key that those evolve
and change over time and grow hopefully
adding value to their particular
business approach but if you think that
of those for Microsoft has the richest
or most open ecosystem raise your hand
five six seven most open okay we'll go
to apple okay let's go to Google or
let's go to IBM
very interesting okay iBM has it by
probably about three or four folks I
think by the time I'm done speaking we
might have a different perception set oh
yeah the one light late vote doesn't
count well that's a given they always
can be improved and we'll talk a little
bit about what we've done to open ours
up I think in a in a pretty significant
way the one thing I kind of summarize
everything they talked about here is
especially with Neely Cruz and and and
ballmer's pictures up front and not to
these introduction is if the medicine
doesn't kill you it makes you stronger
in the end and I think that's what I'm
going to show you that we've learned in
what we've been doing and I think it's
going to make a significantly stronger
than what we did before so with that I
want to kind of go over a page that you
guys can all pull up and that's the
microsoft com wack protocols page and
this is a great point for you to kind of
dive into from a developer's experience
or from a legal and community standpoint
where you can get information on what
i'm going to be talking about including
tools but this kind of is is the anchor
page for the effort that's gone on over
the last six years to document all of
our protocols and to offer up plugfest
and interop labs to anybody without even
taking a license to all of the work for
our high volume products and it's not
just windows but it's actually office
exchange sequel etc so this goes across
all of our business divisions not just
for windows but i'm going to focus on
what we've done for windows which is
really set the tone and pace for
actually all the rest of the divisions
as well so with that let me kind of dive
into some of the stats this happens to
be about half of the effort that we've
done and this slide is going to
highlight what we've done for the
Department of Justice in the US Antony
alluded to the European Union which was
focusing on server to server protocols
primarily in a work group setting and
has kind of an interesting definition of
the
boundaries one of the challenges has
been to actually take the words that the
lawyers wrote down that describe some
environment or ecosystem actually
translated into reality both in what the
European Union Commission is set as well
as our own Department of Justice those
boundaries are not easily defined
actually in fact they're very hazy and
unclear and opaque as much as possible
so with that in the u.s. we have
actually documented and tested 222
protocols about 23,000 pages and taken
those and converted them and extracted
requirements we're getting there hold
off good question within that set of
that corpus if you take an RFC style
must or should in terms of language
we've extracted almost 37,000
requirements that actually have to be
tested to say that what was written in
the specification actually occurs in the
system so a packet is sent at this
particular time between this machine and
that machine we need to either
synthetically create that packet and
make sure that the server responds in
the same way as a client does or we have
to observe it if we're actually using a
real client to drive the particular
system that is a lot of testing okay
within that about sixty percent of those
protocols were tested with an approach
called model-based testing with one of
the tools that we actually inherited and
adopted in terms of a product from MSR
which is a fantastic technology transfer
story as well called spec explorer I'll
talk more about that later thirty one
percent of the protocols were tested
using traditional test cases where they
were serialized in and unwritten case by
case in a very linear kind of coding
approach so within that we had about
67,000 person days of effort to do just
this set this is this is half of it
actually because if you actually add in
the European Union requirements you
about double this so
the last four years probably to the tune
of about if you add it all up probably
about 75 million dollars a year in both
the documentation and the testing effort
for the last three to four years
significant effort so here's a little
bit of a break out in terms of the
traditional versus model-based testing
and we've had a good chance to actually
do some some statistical analysis on the
efficiency of either modeling the
protocol or developing it just using a
traditional test approach the
model-based efforts were significantly
more efficient and not only that they're
easier to maintain in the long run
because you can tweak the model and
regenerate all of your test cases on the
fly so there's a lot of benefit to doing
this including taking that same model
and drought driving it back into your
system for fuzz testing for security etc
etc etc you get more and more benefits
once you've actually modeled that
particular part portion of the system so
with that I'll kind of describe
model-based testing in it in a nutshell
who here is more familiar with it than I
am even raise your hand if you know what
model-based testing is like these two
guys know it because they're my subject
matter experts world world experts on it
in fact so far there's any tough
questions later I'll probably point to
Wolfgang or Nico so you start with the
requirements that are in the
specification first thing you have to do
is efficiently extract those who manage
those ok we had to build tools for that
including some of the things that we're
pushing for in the next version of
visual studio which will be fantastic
requirement management from beginning to
end so once you have the requirements
extracted somebody thinks about them and
develops an abstract view of those
requirements and develops a model from
the model you might have to go back and
find some more implicit requirements you
kind of get it right and to the point
where you're solid with the model you
can then generate the tests in a test
suite from that you have expected
outputs that you need to compare it to
to see that the actual resultant is is a
valid system response
then you can go down and say all right
you actually have to run it now against
the real world system so this is where
you put the real server on the other end
or client depending on which which
perspective you're trying to verify and
from that you compare the two for what
actually happened and you either get a
pass or a fail and then you either fix
implementation where we have many times
where security vulnerability has been
found from this effort or you go up and
you fix the documentation the
specification which says that you got it
wrong the system actually behaves and
does something different pretty
straightforward but pretty complex in
terms of doing it at scale like we've
done so some of the cool things that
we've done in modeling around spec
explorer were well let's leverage visual
studio so we built it as a plug-in this
is now available and i'll give you a
pointer in the next slide to where you
can pick this up the styles and
languages that we want to support have
to be pretty rich the protocols that
we've developed over the last 20 years
25 years for all versions of windows are
in some cases worse than looking at a
plate of spaghetti okay ugly I mean all
sorts of rules that you would like to
have in a nice layered system are broken
all right people do things at various
layers and you go oh my god how can we
possibly have done that so you have to
have a pretty darn rich way to express
those you've got a synchronous non
deterministic system state machine
extractions from the model program test
code generation is an interesting thing
where you want to develop libraries to
do that efficiently from protocol a
protocol where those behaviors you don't
want to re-implement time after time and
then model composition and actually this
is one of the toughest things we're
still working on is once you get all
these things modeled and they're all
have layering how do you actually
combine them and actually can you run
them holistically versus a piecemeal
something that really kind of pushes
computational capabilities and interface
definitions between relation related
protocols so with that here's a quick
snap snap screenshot of spec Explorer
running in visual studio
this is actually for smb2 which is a
very popular file system protocol that
samba for example is implementing that
we've worked very very closely with
improving their testing as well as our
testing to run against their
implementations in the ecosystem and
here's one particular snapshot of the
system running you can you can drill in
you can drill out you can actually look
at the test cases as they run here and
it's quite quite fascinating that the
tough thing about this is that most of
these models become so large and so
complex how do you find what's
interesting becomes one of the the
toughest challenges that you've got to
solve so how you slice these models and
make it something that will run in a
reasonable amount of time and validate
for what you're looking for is something
that we've done with inspected floor
explore that you can look at yourself
and find more out online the place to
get that is msdn microsoft com dev labs
and i think that the link actually
there's a visual studio location for
some other I think there's also some
videos and some other tutorials that
that you can walk through up there as
well if you have any questions on that
please send me an email and I'll get you
in touch with the right folks on this
there's a number of interesting ways to
extend this and I'm going to talk a
little bit about what we're doing in the
future and I think there's a lot of
opportunity to extend this in some
interesting ways happy to engage from an
academic standpoint on a lot of this
tough problems that we've had in this
going forward including how it applies
to what we're doing in the cloud with
the juror so the challenge is going
forward we kind of backed into this for
years ago with an open problem saying
one document all these protocols and
then to make sure they're accurate and
usable and that has not been an easy
thing to do because we have a lot of
masters for this data if you think about
it we had existing specs that were
written on how we created windows not
always perfect and obviously not
maintained
you know in in the best cases when
products evolve and change we have the
code which is the real ultimate master
the it'll the interfaces the actual code
itself which most often we had to go
back and reference especially with
people that had moved on in and we had
you know basically stubs of things that
were not even used anymore that we were
we were required to document and that we
did parsers that need to be written so
that we can actually see the traffic on
the wire for network sniffers like
Wireshark or net Mon which is also
something that we ship and integrate
into this the models themselves test
Suites models they just referenced
before where things we just created that
renew test Suites and inventory records
etc all of that basically is independent
and what we need to do is make sure all
of those actually drive and are
maintained going forward in sync not an
easy easy challenge to say the least
part of the other problem was it's just
tough to see what's going on the wire
there's performance issues a lot of
things are encrypted how do you do it
you gotta break through all those
barriers so making the system more
diagnose a diagnosis of all is actually
something that's an upcoming product of
this as well and changes that we're
making the future versions of the
operating system in pretty significant
ways so with that this is a kind of a
pictorial description of the multi
master problem that we have today
somebody conceives a protocol design
most of its in their head a little bit
of it gets written down into some code
or to a prototype a little bit of it
goes into a spec okay a little bit of it
gets stored somewhere over that says hey
we have a protocol some of it goes into
this parser thing that's actually
written from the code we have some
testing that goes on and then we have a
model that's that's tested and all of it
kind of floats in is its own entity okay
not ideal so what we're doing going
forward is starting at the design stage
with an architect saying all right let's
express it in a new notation called open
protocol notation and from that you can
drive the code
stubs and proxies you can drive the
skeleton of the documentation which is
probably about sixty percent of the
document maybe even more the network
parser itself so you can see the traffic
when you want to look at the prototype
the test adapters test Suites and the
inventory record all of it from one
master and you can round trip to
actually establish the master OPN to
begin with to bootstrap it from things
that you may already have in code or
other places using static analysis to
help but we're want to get to this as
quickly as we can and i think that the
actual ecosystem can leverage this as
well given that a lot of these things
we're already sharing and will share
including the approach on how how to
maintain this so here's just an example
of it being used with an interface
definition that's being used to
bootstrap oto OPN because you don't want
to start from scratch there's a lot of
this stuff exists but we want to
maintain OPN as a sole single repository
of this information going forward dev
arch works on OPN iterates on it once
you've bootstrapped it you create a word
document writer takes it actually
finishes it off with some polish and
extra descriptions on things in terms of
of what you want to describe and you can
go publish it just one example of a
chain that we want to use it in so
there's a lot of things that we have to
do to be expressive enough to actually
describe this kind of sub system within
OPN here's a few of the examples you
know I'm not going to go into details on
this we're willing to share and provide
some of this information in terms of
early glimpses of where we're at on what
we're doing around open we intend to be
very open with open that's hence part of
the name even and and as we progress on
this front in terms of the basic
infrastructure will be sharing that on
some of our codeplex galleries and other
opportunities for you to interact with
if you'd like a little bit more detail
on each of the particular areas between
the data how we express the data how we
express the behaviors and the fun
Shin allottee what the system is
actually doing the relationship to other
systems a lot of works gone on in the
past we're leveraging a lot of the
things that we've learned from the past
and much of this is currently based on
some of the work that we've been doing
for quite a number of years at Microsoft
on the M language so here's a little bit
of the implementation details on the
runtime side of what we do around the
protocol object model kind of the guts
of how we take anything on the the input
and output side pretty straightforward
today we have ran just completed running
a new document through this system which
is related to the documents called is TM
it's a nice guzzi document which which
we piloted with the system and it's
worked fantastic including a new
authoring system that uses some pretty
cool hooks into word to control the the
publishing cycle of it where are we
going there's a lot of things that we'd
like to improve in this one is we want
to make sure that the the core itself
not just the the protocol object model
but all of their surrounding components
to do the tests sweet generation from
open are completed that we can actually
compose these and leverage them in and
build the rest of the parsers from open
that we've already done and I think Dave
what's the current count on a number of
parsers that we have for the current
parser or design npl so right s'alright
alright I'll repeat that just for for
the for the video we have about 500
current protocol parsers available in
the existing net Mon parser language
that we'll need to ultimately be
converted to OPN but we have a lot of
other things to do a lot of this is
obviously around consistency checking
based on the models how do we establish
a really easy way for the ecosystem to
verify that what they've built or what
they want to extend from our particular
platform is working the way that we
expect it now this isn't even this is
critical for us as well as our partners
and having the best tools to do that are
essential to actually developing a more
stable and a more predictable ecosystem
especially as we start to compose things
faster and faster with what we're
offering up with the juror for example
how do you verify that something that's
running on premise runs identically when
it's in the cloud and whether it's a
private cloud or a public cloud and how
does a more complex system in terms of
reliability run even within one of those
environments so how does your
reliability really go up to four or five
nines that's not an easy thing to do
when you have these kinds of inter place
between hardware software and you have
seven or eight or ten 12 layers in the
stack that you have to determine our
acting either appropriately or not and
then in the end how do you point the
finger of whose problem it is the faster
you can do that and the more reliable
you can do that the more confidence you
have with your end customers all of this
helps us to do that not only to do what
we have to do for the next 10 to 15
years from a regulatory standpoint but
that medicine that we've taken I think
is actually going to significantly
improve how we interact with our
partners from a quality perspective
using some of these tools we've got a
long ways to go and we're really looking
forward to input from a number of people
we've talked to a number of you guys in
different capacities about what we're
doing going forward with open protocol
notation and the
the overall protocol engineering
framework or path that we call it and
how those components can actually come
together and kind of extend from where
we're at we have good basis for this I
think it's pretty an exciting thing that
we're going to be doing going forward so
with that Anthony why we take any
questions on what I just went through
and the overall of both presentations
happy happy to open it up thanks very
much afraid you want to lost your
question again no just questions for
anybody um I have one question um if you
have no design in the beginning and then
you try to define an interface to
something that hasn't been well designed
chances are you won't find a simple
interface specification it seems to me
to avoid having more of a mess in the
future it would be nice if the initial
designs of the interfaces had some
design in them so what kind of programs
do you have in place to eliminate the
rough edges of the current designs and
turn them into something that's much
more manageable in the future oh that's
it that's a great question for one
depending on the how deeply ingrained
that interface is as ugly it is as it is
you're going to love it for a long long
time if you like it or not and you can
evolve and move people to a new
interface and you clean it up but if I
get your question correctly it you look
at the servicing life of some of these
things that you've that you've built we
still have custom contracts for NT 3.51
okay it won't ever go away in some
regard it's almost down to zero but you
actually have to live with things that
you do so the best thing to do is to
prevent the ugliness and that's through
education better modeling and
understanding of the behaviors whether
it be performance problems or complexity
for implementation and better education
you create a new new interface or new
protocol that this helps given our
repository of our mistakes that we've
made and ability to reuse what we
already have most of the time you don't
need a new one actually people build
something that's slightly different and
it becomes not ideal in some situations
that from what we found so but you know
there's a range of solutions to that one
is you do evolve interface and you say
there's a new version okay and you
slowly move people off of it but you're
not going to get to wholesale retirement
anytime soon if you have an adopted base
that's fairly large best thing to do is
you know avoid it you know that no magic
solution there though this actually
showcases it in a fast way what not to
do when you go through this exercise you
have an answer to that I mean you could
reasonably you could reasonably
speculate that's at least some portion
of the difficulties Microsoft ran into
in the early days in terms of the
quality of its protocol documentation
which largely due to the inherent
difficulties the protocols that they
were trying to in here in complexity of
the protocols they were trying to doc
you document and what's more the
technology substrate on which those
things on which those things were were
built and asks you know as time rolls on
the feasibility of developing things in
a more in a more systematic way becomes
becomes better yeah that the study of
this is actually very interesting when
you look at the business demands when
you look at how an actual interface
evolved where things were done how they
were done a lot of a lot of mistakes are
done based on pressure on time to
release on interesting dynamics of of
what group does what and this is even
between open source and Microsoft etc
there's there's that the study of that
is actually a pretty interesting area
and we're learning more and more about
that here I mean I think there's a
strong
Conway's law you know is a pretty
strongly affect how these things are how
these things are constructing you can
see the imprint of Microsoft's own
technology evolution in its protocol
specs in an organizational evolution in
its protocols yeah that one of the one
of the groups of course as Fred said is
microsoft research and the session is
also organized by two of the researchers
one of them is over there tomball and
four from was here but he slipped out so
oh no there he is well from shelter
tomball they're also organizing this
whole track of lectures that we've
gotten this is just the first one search
very briefly one other thing to mention
which is in the talk about multiple
masters i might add on one extra master
which is something that isn't considered
as much as it should be which is
intellectual property assets of course
what you've got is you've got some of
the protocols and some other information
embedded in patents and other sources
with serious ecosystem and commercial
constraints operating operating over
that and it's quite interesting that in
the software engineering community we
don't discuss IP assets like patterns as
much as we should do so two questions
actually one for Anthony and 11 for Fred
and the one to you Anthony is that have
you looked at some of the work that the
MIS folks are doing a business idea
alignment and so on you know to try and
tie in the business models and things
like that to the way these IT
departments work you know they're doing
some reasonable work in that area and
the second question to fred is using
this kind of program analysis have you
been able to sort of correlate what you
find with this bottom-up program
analysis with the business goals
you know captured in some kind of
machine readable way you know try to
correlate the two to see if the
architecture is meeting those goals in
some manner I mean I'm aware that there
is interesting work in that in the MIS
community and I should devote more time
to to having a look at it so it's a good
it's a good it's a very good point it's
a very good pointer the other way I
think I can just say no it it's complex
enough to try to represent the code in a
rational way taking another step to tie
that directly to business goals or or
outcomes is even harder I mean there are
goals set for certain features that you
can't I but in terms of what we've
looked at at this point in time or
really thought through we haven't gone
to that level yes there's some very
interesting work being done on the by
the Indian in the traceability
requirements traceability community on
using information retrieval techniques
to tie business documents to other
development or development artifacts and
you know seeing us in inside Microsoft's
repositories they've got a lot of
business documents powerpoints and stuff
like that all over the place it may be
quite interesting to actually try and
apply those techniques in that settings
one place where people have been looking
at them oh I think is the open source
community particular recommendation
talk just closer your mouth tiny switch
is it on now yeah there's a book by by
Richard Gabriel and Ron Goldman called
innovation happens elsewhere which it
talks a lot about your business issues
how they make and I just in general you
know the open source people have have
noticed you know that a lot of projects
fail and a lot of them succeed know what
they talk about the the personal issues
not just social issues not just the
technical ones and actually since the
two guys I mentioned when they wrote the
book we're both at son I would also like
to point out that although it is true
that if you're basing your business on
an ecosystem and the eco system fails
that your business will fail a son also
shows that you can have a very
successful ecosystem and still not make
money off of it that you know it's
important to figure out you know how
you're going to use the ecosystem to
know to make money and and yeah the I I
mean I'd like to to you know warmly
agree with both both sentiments firstly
that there's been some interesting work
done in the study of open source
development development that would be
hot that's highly relevant to study of
software ecosystems but perhaps more
warmly still to welcome the second
observation which is that the question
of the question of how people can make
money within such ecosystems is really
is really important and it it's
important not just to ask the question
about what needs to be open but also the
question about what needs what you
actually need to not what actually need
to not open and there is an interesting
dividing lines so I've seen actually
premieres at the back and Prem did some
very interesting work on on testing and
encryption of testing so that you could
perhaps get test results without knowing
the details of the code that was ten
that was tested there's a whole lot of
interesting work that might be able to
be done that might look at these issues
about coherence within a large ecosystem
but somehow prevent information leakage
that loses you commercial advantage so
I'm very interested in those questions
yeah I just wanted to follow on that
Carlos baldwin at Harvard Business
School has actually been doing research
on this issue that you're talking about
you mentioned and she she's a specialist
in modularity of businesses and how that
relates to modularity of software you
know she wrote the co-author of the book
design rules the power of modularity
she's given some key notes at our
software engineering conferences anyway
sheet which he says is that when you
modular eyes an interface you're
creating options for substitution and
when a company does that you create
options for competitors to substitute
components underneath you and she gives
case studies for IBM for example when
they created the IBM PC and with a
modular architecture they basically end
up giving away the whole business same
thing happened with OS 360 and those
system/360 etc when they had to give up
their assembly language according to you
know the FTC or ever made that ruling
and so I think there's she talks about
the importance of non modularity and
preserving business value which I guess
is you know we talk about protocols
that's essentially modularity you
basically want to take away certain
options if you're not going to be the
one who's going to be exercising them so
very interesting and in fact obvious she
talks about abuse gated interfaces
hidden interfaces it's very very
interesting that there's not a lot of
incentive for businesses to create these
interfaces if they're giving away their
business value thanks thanks very much
for them and I think that's a wonderful
place
to stop because then we can thank our
two speakers for introducing us to this
new concept which we can now go out and
think about and wrestle with and take
forward and want to thank them very very
much for doing so thanks Fred thanks
thank you to the X like